snapchat allows users to post send and
receive photos and videos that are
automatically deleted after short period
of time but many people have found out
the hard way that they're hilarious and
embarrassing snapchat stories aren't
safe from being captured and reposted
online for millions of people to laugh
at if you're new to our channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit the thumbs
up button because today we're talking
about ten people who failed hard at
snapchat blame the beam have you ever
experienced the sheer horror of being
trapped in an automobile with an insect
that's determined to make your life a
living hell
well this snapchat user experienced this
terror firsthand and documented the
aftermath on the social media app sadly
a perfectly good taco was completely
destroyed in the process let's hope no
bees were hurt ins incident meatloaf
we're still trying to figure out why
people think it's funny or necessary to
document their toilet experiences and
this snapchat user definitely took
things a step too far not only does she
photograph herself while using the
bathroom but she also felt the need to
describe the horrifying smelling great
detail the caption reads got the
bathroom smelling like meatloaf and we
sure do feel sorry for the unlucky
person in the stall next to her who had
to catch a whiff stuck in traffic
getting stuck in traffic can raise your
blood pressure cause you pull your hair
out and make you curse like a sailor
there's absolutely nothing appealing
about traffic so we're completely
confused why this snapchat user thought
it would be cool to actually pretend to
be stuck in gridlock with the pout on
his face he took a selfie during his
morning commute but if you look in the
reflection of sunglasses there's
absolutely no traffic in sight this my
friends is what we call an epic snapchat
fail woke up to this things got a bit
weird at this sleepover and thankfully
one snapchat user documented the whole
thing two guys fell asleep on the floor
and at some point during the night one
of the guys moved in for a bit of
cuddling his hand is completely
underneath his pal shirt and we're
pretty sure they were both horrified
when they woke up and saw this
embarrassing moment had been posted on
the social media app for the world to
see caught in the act
this guy had a sneaking suspicion that
his girlfriend was cheating on him
instead of handling the heartbreak
moment in private he decided to upload
the in
demise of his relationship for our
viewing pleasure the birth snap is
captioned about to catch her cheating
and the second photo shows his
girlfriend with a pillow covering her
body and the devastating caption that
simply says destroyed we really hate to
lap someone else's misery we really do
but it's so hard not to dog-paddle a man
decided to take his dog for a walk but
sadly he didn't even realize this poor
dog was going for a swim instead a
snapchat user snapped a photo of this
epic fail along with the caption should
I tell him thankfully the pup looks like
a dog title Pro watch out Michael Phelps
you've got some competition brother in
town forever Lea loved these two
siblings were so excited to see each
other they decided to upload a photo to
snapchat showing just how much they
really care about one another
but this loving moment turned into a
complete snapchat failed both guys are
shirtless and it looks like they may
even be lying in bed together um awkward
invisible Bay instead of going out and
finding a real girlfriend this guy
decided to use an invisible Bay we're
hoping he was just extremely bored and
wanted to make his followers laugh
because this is probably one of the
worst snapchat fails ever he's on the
floor with his eyes closed and the
caption reads lol they caught me
sleeping but he's lying in front of a
mirror and you can see him in the
reflection that he's using a speech tape
a candid shot we're going to give him
points for his flexibility but faking a
bay is definitely a fail pool fail do
you ever get jealous when you see your
snapchat friends heading off to tropical
locations well maybe you shouldn't be so
jealous after all because it's quite
possible certification pictures are
nothing more than some photo trickery to
snapchat user used his fingers and his
desktop background to trick his
followers into thinking he was getting
some rest and relaxation in front of a
beautiful pool he later fess up to his
own snapchat fail by saying jokes I have
no life well he was read about that one
how a woman in her boyfriend decided to
snapchat themselves driving the car at
111 miles per hour
they were pictured laughing and smiling
but those smiles turned into frowns when
they lost control of their car and were
trapped inside until help arrived
the woman continued documenting the
entire
or deal on snapchat with blood dripping
down her face and all thankfully the two
of them made it out alive so we don't
feel so bad for completely cracking up
and her bloody selfie with a caption
that reads help
which of these snapchat fails is your
favorite leave us a comment below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
you